good morning John I'm in a hotel in
Portsmouth New Hampshire New Hampshire
rhymes with new hamster and a hamster is
something that I don't have I have
decided to do this video as a series of
open letters an open letter of course
being a letter that I write to someone
or something that everyone gets to see
not just the person or thing that I
write the letter to so without further
ado a short letter to my knees this is
written on a piece of my nephew's
finger-painting it's very nice isn't it
do your knees thank you for not sucking
I know that I worked pretty hard to make
you not suck I don't do any of the
really horrible things like backcountry
downhill skiing but sometimes I do bang
the crap out of you while I'm dancing
and I thank you very much for not having
yet given up on me even though you are
sort of disgustingly purple dear
downtown Boston I have never been
anywhere more confusing in my life the
GPS machine I think actually killed
itself it gave up on life because of you
I suggest you knock everything down and
rebuild completely or outlaw cars those
are my only suggestions to you dear Alex
Christina Lizzy at Collin and Sam thank
you so much for waiting on a street
corner while I searched all of downtown
Boston for the parking garage that I
parked in and I didn't know where the
parking garage was and it was like the
worst experience of my life because my
show was gonna start in 30 minutes and
you are all so nice about my complete
ineptitude and then you cooperated to
get all seven us into the car and to
Cambridge where everyone enjoyed a great
Boston area show - Howie Mandel I don't
care what kind of financial problems you
have dealer No Deal is not okay when
that group of people proposed that idea
to you you should have taken a rubber
band and flapped it on each of their
faces and then walked out of the room
that is the only acceptable response to
the idea of Deal or No Deal to everyone
who's ever wanted to puke but didn't
thank you so much especially those of
you who were in my car at the time not
puking despite wanting to puke is one of
those ordinary everyday acts of heroism
that often go unnoticed but the world is
a better place because of you people
through the city of Cambridge you are
now my favorite city in the world I just
wanted to let you know that I left my
MacBook Pro on the passenger seat of my
car with the window down for two and a
half hours and none of the kind of
thoughtful passers-by helped themselves
to it - JK Rowling you know I like what
you do your stuff is the best stuff out
there but not even you deserve a fan
community so awesome as Harry Potter
nerds
no one deserves that I hope you know how
lucky you are to the staff of the leaky
cauldron good and Lord you people party
like it's the end of the frickin world
thank you for letting me be a part of it
to North Korea WTF guys think about this
for a second like I don't care if you
have nuclear weapons but if you start
thinking about using them the world is
going to combine its efforts and turn
your entire country into glass you don't
want that I don't want that nobody wants
that so give up now
- lilacs you guys are awesome well done
but you've got a ways to go before you
smell as good as iris and those are all
of my open letters for the day John I
will see you soon